pas mal que tu sois revenu parce que
latendresse a exigé ou soit par x
tout le monde est là alors à nancy
les séries créations originales canal+
n'ont pas fini de vous étonner
toi tu invites rentrer en france moi
j'ai envie de travailler avec vous même
étiez de l'or c'est pas le boulot qui
manque toute façon si c'est pas toi ce
sera quelqu'un d'autre je sais bien que
dans le genre de ski allemand peer
sophie cet homme dans le paiement de mon
ami chez hugo dagod enchanté la manua ça
va vous envahir ils se répondent voilà
et vous bouffe la vie
je m'en occupe pas moi je connais bien
les psychopathes versailles est un joyau
étincelant qui brille dans la nuit
c'est la beauté c'est le pouvoir
vous avez beau être le roi soleil
lorsque je vous regarde dans les yeux je
ne vois que de l'ombre et rien d'autre
qu'est ce que tu fais exactement c'est
quoi ton plan
ce directeur pour la première fois j'ai
pas de plan
ça me fait plaisir de voir
alors on s'est pas compris je ne demande
pas l'autorisation je dis ce que je vais
faire
en 2017 retour très attendu et nouveaux
univers créations originales canal+
[Musique]